hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is the
progressive commentator and the host of
the david pakman show right here on
youtube david pakman welcome to
trigonometry thank you for having me
what have you liked about uh the biden
administration and are you still of the
view that that was the right choice in
terms of voting for biden the two from
the two options it was the right choice
i mean to to speak candidly with you
gentlemen
donald trump was a humiliating
embarrassment i mean just the
the promises he made
none of them were kept you know he was
going to build a wall he didn't build it
he was going to
solve the israeli-palestinian conflict
jared actually was going to solve it his
son-in-law as you know it hasn't been
solved he was i mean there was a look
there was a lot of progress on that
would you concede that
don't well what progress was there
the well the israeli foreign minister
turning up in saudi arabia i mean all of
that stuff and better relations between
the countries in the region did you not
feel that that was some progress what
changed materially
uh
look but maybe let's not spend too much
time on it so you did anything
let me put it this way did anything
change materially
i think it's quite a difficult situation
to change materially in the course of a
four-year presidency but so it didn't
that's fair okay we agree it didn't
change materially they did do some
optics things you know there was a
flight like from tel aviv to uae but i
think we're on the same page we can't
neither one of us can identify anything
that changed materially is that
um i i what i would say is i think some
progress was made in a very difficult
situation i don't claim that the
situation became
dramatically different and we are now
like way way towards a solution and also
i think i'd also consider it's not an
issue i know enough about to have a
proper discussion with you as well
that's fair let's let's we'll we can
table it on that on that basis
um no listen i mean as far as joe biden
joe biden's not exciting to me you know
i'm a progressive social democrat so joe
biden's not exciting he did some good
things so he did a third covet stimulus
at a time that i think it was necessary
extended a pause on student loans got a
pretty good infrastructure bill passed
got us out of afghanistan which i think
was a great thing i think that that was
a quagmire
but be oh yeah oh my god i mean we were
there no i agree with you with a
quagmire point but did you feel that the
way that was done went well
i think it went as well as it would have
gone no matter who did it
wow
interesting i mean when asked trump was
asked what would you have done
differently
and he literally couldn't articulate a
single difference so at least
trump was going to do it and he another
failed promise
biden did it and when trump was given
the opportunity to articulate how he
would have handled it differently
he couldn't name a single difference so
let me in the most factual way possible
i've not heard
trump explain what would have gone
differently and therefore i have no
basis on which to assume it would have
is that fair
i suppose it is i su the question for me
is i i
i mean
i struggle to imagine going any worse so
i kind of feel like there is a
possibility that the preparations could
have gone better is that do you think
that's unfair i have a struggle to
imagine it could have gone better so
like i think where i land is it went the
way i expected you know and and it was
correct ultimately to get out okay
please carry on i'll interrupt you
um
bye you're talking about whether you're
happy with the biden presence yeah i
mean it's like listen um
he's doing exactly what i expected you
know i didn't expect him to do anything
on cannabis decriminalization and he's
not and i didn't expect any at least in
the first two years immigration reform
and we're not getting it so you know my
i try not to become jaded or cynical but
basically i've seen from biden exactly
what i expected okay
you mentioned trump being a humiliation
and look uh uh you know neither francis
or i were pro-trump um i thought
i thought he raised some important
issues by the way uh you know and
immigration not not not being least of
those we can have a conversation about
that maybe later on but um if if trump
was a humiliation perhaps in the way
that he talked and you you mentioned
some of the promises that he didn't
deliver on the optics of the biden
president presidency do they do they not
make you cringe somewhat when he's
shaking hands in mid-air with people who
aren't there and forgetting things and
all that
beautiful so are you guys open to a good
faith conversation about that absolutely
okay absolutely okay so let's go piece
by piece
um does joe biden sometimes lose his
train of thought absolutely
absolutely there's no question about it
and he's close to 80 years old if you
compare joe biden today to joe biden
when he ran circles around paul ryan in
2012 it's not the same guy i have no
problem saying that that's absolutely
the case
no argument whatsoever
the shaking hands with midair video was
a total joke and i'll tell you the story
about it the weekend that that story you
know the shaking hands with midair
i looked at the clip on my phone and it
was a very short clip where you just see
biden stop speaking he turns to the side
and he goes like this
i said oh my goodness this is it this is
terrible biden he seems worse than trump
when trump came off of his plane
and his car was right in front of him
and trump wandered off and was brought
back by the arm by a secret service
agent and they said here's your car that
lit that's worse than when trump had
rudy giuliani sitting right across the
table and said
where where's rudy said maybe i'll ask
rudy to say a few words
you
thank you very very much mr president
first of all congratulations on
what is in fact a historic uh start of
an administration i've never seen so
much done
in so short a period of time
this that biden clip looked bad
um and i was going to report like guys
this something seems wrong with joe
biden and then i found like a the actual
full
frame instead of the square twitter
video
and you could see what happened after
and joe biden had people to his right
and to his back right and to his back
and and he literally finished the speech
and turned and said something to the
people to the right and then he turns
back and he does the exact same thing
and then to the other side and does the
exact same thing so
that was
a non-story for me it was a completeness
i hear you yeah david i'll i haven't
done enough research and i'll admit it
readily that i don't know whether that's
accurate but i'm happy for the purpose
of this discussion to accept that fair
but would you accept that joe biden
mentally is not at his peak i think you
already have i already have yeah
so
is is that not a humiliation
when i say a humiliation i go by what is
global opinion of the united states
that's my because i'm one guy right and
so what what is so i want to say what
does the world think
and we know because of global gallup
studies and global pew studies and
others
that opinion of the united states as an
as a country
of the us's ability to lead of the
president of the united states it was in
the toilet to use a phrase trump likes
you know to flush 10 or 15 times opinion
was in the toilet under trump and it is
recovered dramatically under biden so i
try to take myself out of it and just
say what does the world think and
there's a couple of exceptions
russia liked trump better than biden
again this is not
rhetorical it's just the opinion polls
russia did like trump better than biden
i think turkey liked trump better than
biden
and for some this may be wrong but i
think i have nigeria in my mind like
trump better than biden but other than
that
empirically
our global reputation has recovered
dramatically under biden so that's my
standard that i use david let's talk
about culture i know that it's not
necessarily a big thing for you
but in terms of some of the things we've
been putting to you that we are
sensitive to which is how culture
affects how people feel about their
country about the party that they want
to vote for about the direction of
travel of their society i would probably
chart three issues on which a lot of
people in our space which is perhaps
disaffected lefties or people who are
sort of centrists like me or people who
are right-leaning uh that have been
concerned about
uh and feel are important and are not
being discussed honestly in in the
mainstream space let's say right i think
number one certainly in the uk you tell
me what you think about the united
states but is number one is immigration
number two is race relations and all the
stuff to do with blm and all of that and
number three as of late these sort of
big toxic issues is of course the trans
issue
okay so
sure those are three issues yes yeah
yeah
i was going somewhere with i just wanted
to get confirmation that those are
issues that exist absolutely those are
issues that exist and what i am
asserting to you is there are quite a
lot of people uh certainly here in the
uk uh and i know that in america it's
the same in some circles that feel very
strongly about those issues and they
feel that the mainstream conversation
about those issues is dishonest so if we
start in reverse order with the trans
thing
can i can i it's a dick move to ask you
this but can i ask you to define a woman
is that okay yeah so listen i mean i did
a whole thing with this right-wing guy
named michael knowles a little while ago
okay
you know we were talking about the
definition of a woman and the context
was um the katanji brown jackson
hearings and her refusal to answer and
there i argued that makes perfect sense
because they're asking in a legal
context the question is who can bring a
discrimination lawsuit on the basis of
gender and i thought she was right not
to answer it and i made the point that
depending on where you're asking the
question the answer could actually be
different now i'm glad to give my view
of this socially if that's okay sure
yeah of course so this is again and the
problem with this and i know you guys
would never do this because you seem so
honest the problem is that sometimes
this question is then used to put
someone in a corner so i will say in
advance that the definition i have will
not work in every setting okay like for
example the definition i have in an ob
gyn's office may not work because we
recognize biological differences right
but for me
the broadest way where i think about
who am i going to relate to as a woman
it would be somebody
who i identify
as
deliberately
trying to exist in the world as a woman
and so okay if i see a biological man
who
and again we we have to talk about this
in candid ways which some people might
not like but i think it's necessary if i
see if if i see me
with a wig on
it's not going to be apparent to me that
that's someone who is necessarily trying
to exist in the world as a woman if they
go by the name david and their their
voice is like mine and they dress like
me so
i'm just going to make the best faith
effort i can where if it's if it's
indicated through a number of different
cues that someone is trying to exist in
the world as a woman i'll relate to them
as a woman that's fine it just doesn't
bother me oh sure and in fact i am kind
of where you are in the sense that we've
had a [ __ ] ton of trans people on the
show and we call them by whatever name
they have and the pronouns that they
they've chosen right i've got no issue
with that however
my issue is that in
and again this is being straight with
you i hope you don't take offense to
what i'm saying please in your in your
refusal to to give a definition that is
equally applicable in different
circumstances you're kind of avoiding
the difficult elements of this right
well the difficult elements are the
exactly that which if okay i'm sorry i
interrupted it
and let me i know you know where i'm
going but let me just give the example
so people know what we're talking about
so we have a a number of cases here in
the uk for example and i know you've had
some in the u.s as well where a trans
woman who still has a male anatomy has
been housed in a female prison and has
gone on to commit sexual assault against
women in prison right okay we obviously
have had uh trans women in male sport in
female sports where they in my opinion
have an unfair advantage uh and there
are other situations in which our
failure to give a clear like universal
definition means that women in
particular in this very instance are
suffering the consequences of our social
unwillingness to be quite hard-lined
about it would you agree with that well
there's that's that's what in in a in a
court they would say that that's a
compound question and we've really got
to break down each of those because
whether i agree with everything you said
i don't know
so let's let's i'm not even sure where
to start so um okay i mean
in prison there was a sexual assault by
a biological male housed with women okay
i i don't know the story
we have a country of 331 million in the
united states so you can find examples
sort of of everything um
sexual assault by biological females of
other females in american prisons is
really common so for me
what i go to is less about you know
trans people i think are one-third of
one percent of the population in the u.s
i i may be slightly off about that but
let's use that as a working number
for me
every assault is bad
and the bigger issue is american prisons
are terrible at keeping inmates safe and
i apply that to men's prisons and
women's prisons
but but you're deflecting here aren't
you i don't well but no i don't think
and so but let me let me go first let me
give you the reverse of your argument
right now but well
it wasn't even shooting black people is
is bad but the real problem is something
else and we shouldn't talk about the
cops shooting black people no that's
kind of why that's not the argument i'm
making okay sure go ahead sorry so the
the point that i'm making is but you
know because that what you're saying is
it's i guess it depends on what you say
the other issue really is that you
didn't get to the end of that and so i
don't know
that's the right wing argument black on
black crime is the real thing forget
about culture and black people right but
those are totally different things what
i'm saying is
violence in prison is a major problem
and i don't deny that an added layer of
complexity is yeah in which prison
should
a trans person be i don't pretend to
have the answer in all cases i don't i
don't pretend to have the answer i'm
conceding it's very complicated
is it complicated if you have a penis
should you be in a female prison
well but not everybody who's a trans
woman has a penis but these people did
and they were in female prisons both in
your country in an hour i i just don't
know the case i don't know i don't know
the answer
should a person with a penis though be
in a in a female prison it's it's i
would have to know more about how these
decisions are being made i i don't know
enough about how the decisions are made
to be able to say
so i mean listen let me put it let me
put it a different way let me put it a
different way
and i i don't know if anecdotes were
both being so anecdotal that i don't
know if this is even useful but
there are there are many instances
where i could show you a picture of
someone and describe their height and
weight to you
and
it would be very hard to argue that they
should be
in a men's prison for their own safety
i'm not arguing for that we've had trans
people on the show who say we need to
make provisions so that trans people uh
are in a separate facility where they're
going to be safe from males who
otherwise would potentially be a danger
to them right so trans people third
prison for trans people that's what some
people have argued on our shows i'm not
saying you take someone who identifies
as a trans woman and you stick them with
men because i don't think it would end
well for them so i don't lack compassion
what i'm trying to get out with you is
do you envisage circumstances under
which it is right to put a person with a
penis in a female prison
uh i can i can envisage uh theoretical
circumstances where it's the best of the
options that are available yeah i mean
right now there are no third prisons for
trans people and so if you say to me
what is more like i mean like listen
let's just be very up front if you have
if you have a trans woman that is
biologically male and has a penis but is
slight in size and has a very feminine
appearance
by all
statistical likelihood they are far less
likely to assault someone in a women's
prison than they are to be assaulted in
a men's prison and so that's a
particular case where i would say it
makes sense for them to be in a women's
prison yes
okay
we could go we could go around for hours
but look but before we move on in the
situation i outlined do you concede that
it makes more sense for them to be in
the if the only two options are a men's
or women's prison
would a 5-3 biological male with a penis
who is outwardly feminine and and is
seen by the average person as a woman
you're not going to put them in the
men's prison are you i think it'd be
very dangerous to do so fair so we agree
on that that's fair well well we don't
agree on that because i don't think
either of those options is acceptable
and we should look for a solution rather
than going i would love another solution
but it seems like we want to give them
the two current options we are on the
same page
uh
no i i just think both of those options
are completely unacceptable to me and i
think we need a third solution and
that's why i feel strongly about it do
you see what i'm saying i see what
you're saying i i but it sounds like
before you realized it might not look
great to concede it that you agreed in
the two options we have now the female
prison makes more sense
uh i think this is where i'm gonna do it
david pakman and go i think it depends
on the individual circumstances that's
what i'm saying if this person is in
prison because of sexual assault against
women
i don't know that that is the right
choice personally okay i mean maybe in
that case they would be we're now
getting so in the weeds but yeah that's
the case that's why they might be they
might be in solitary confinement anyway
in that situation as i mean we now we're
really getting too narrow i think sure
yeah